we got to talk about this North Korea
thing I'm outraged I just took the time
to Google directions to this place so I
could watch the diplomatic Throwdown
between kim jeong-hoon and donald trump
actual photo but now North Korea is
going back on their word
it is the nuclear summit on the verge of
collapse after a months of cooperation
North Korea threatening to cancel its
meeting with President Trump North Korea
objecting to annual joint military
exercises underway between the u.s. and
South Korea the White House was caught
off guard by North Korea's sudden
about-face what what kind of maniac
suddenly walks away from a nuclear deal
for no specific reason just because they
can this chubby egomaniacal tyrant
cannot be trusted and everybody in
America knows who I'm talking about
right now this dumb hair it is bad
English
it's disgusting Kim might walk away from
these talks after all the work our
president put into them god when I think
of the minutes maybe an hour even that
Trump spent planning planning the tweets
the long breathy calls with Hannity
about what they're wearing to work
tomorrow why would Kim do this to him
if only there was someone to point the
finger at the North Koreans are pointing
the finger directly at the new national
security advisor John Bolton who
suggested over the weekend that the
Libya model as he put it could be the
way forward on denuclearization the
North Koreans now saying that they have
a quote repugnance as they put it toward
Bolton what first off unless repugnance
is a mistranslation of mustache aw
that's just rude second all Bolton
suggested was that Libya was a good role
model for North Korea it's an easy path
to follow
Libya gave up its nuclear program and
pretty soon their country was in ruins
and their leader was captured and killed
by his own people what's not to like him
Wow is that what happens to a long head
when it ages is that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's fine it's gonna be fine I'm worried
about Trump what's this going to do to
his upcoming campaign to win the Nobel
Peace Prize this prize has been Trump's
lifelong dream
right behind threesome in space focus up
Nobel Committee drubbs almost achieved
peace on the Korean Peninsula and almost
always counts in horseshoes and
hand-grenades as well as the game I
invented horse grenades the only game
sponsored by my local glue factory just
just give Trump is Nobel now so what if
he put the cart before the horse horses
love it when the cart is first it gives
them the chance to push for a change and
if they don't wanna hit him with a horse
grenades it's how they learn and I know
Trump's already set aside a spot in his
trophy case right next to his homemade
apprentice Emmy and the macaroni art
that Don Jr and Eric made him this
morning